[Music]
good morning to you it's seven o'clock
you're watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster today president
biden marks his first hundred dates in
office telling congress that america is
on the move again
outlining big spending plans overnight
here this morning's trump pages are
again dominated by the ongoing row
about the pm's refurbishment of his flat
boris johnson says
people are more interested in the
pandemic we'll talk about that with the
vaccines minister nadim zahawi shortly
also today good morning are you ready
for a
training session today it's a game old
bird we'll make the ex-soldier
who's been joined by a fun running
pheasant
on his daily training routine
and also for you today stranger things
the artist who spent lockdown completing
portraits of people
she's never actually met it's thursday
the 29th of april
[Music]
the president of the united states
turning peril into possibility president
biden marks a hundred days in office
outlining his vision for life in the
united states after the pandemic
after just 100 days i can report to the
nation
america is on the move again
another record rise in coronavirus cases
and deaths in india as the united states
donates a hundred million dollars worth
of supplies
no let up in the so-called cash for
curtains row with the pm
still under pressure to explain how the
revamp of his downing street flat was
paid for
the un criticizes britain's decision to
cut
funding for a scheme to prevent
thousands of child deaths in the world's
poorest countries feeling the heat of
climate change a warning the world's
glaciers are melting
twice as fast as 20 years ago
and hey big spender the role mint
unveils the largest coin
it's ever made
the bank holiday weekend will close on a
wet and
windy no but for the time being it stays
chilly with sunshine and showers i'll
have more details on those
before half past
[Music]
well a very good morning to you
president biden has marked his first
hundred days in the white house telling
congress that america
is on the move again and that despite
the pain of the last year the country
will turn
peril into possibility joe biden
outlined a series of ambitious spending
plans
running into trillions of dollars aimed
at boosting family life the minimum wage
and jobs
he also warned he's prepared to stand up
against military
and commercial threats from china alex
rossi reports from washington
madam speaker the president of the
united states
a familiar setting but this would be an
address to congress
like no other with joe biden's
presidency
silhouetted against the backdrop of a
pandemic this was a socially distanced
event
there were a few masked fist bumps but
only a small audience was present
most members watching on tv
but history was also made for another
reason
well madam speaker madam vice president
no president has ever said those words
from this podium no president has ever
said those words
and it's about time
the specter of coronavirus was though
always present
the president highlighting the success
of the vaccination program
everyone look over the age of 16
everyone is now eligible to get
vaccinated right now
right away go get vaccinated america
and it wasn't lost on anyone either that
this very chamber was stormed by
pro-trump supporters
just a few months ago the insurrection
was an existential crisis a test
on whether our democracy could survive
and it did
but the struggle is far from over his
big pitch though
multi-trillion dollar big government
rescue plans for jobs families
and coveted recovery and in the bare pit
of the us's polarized politics
the president didn't completely turn his
back on harnessing
the power of populism american tax
dollars
are going to be used to buy american
products
made in america to create american jobs
that's the way it's supposed to be and
it will be in this administration
uniting the country and fixing racial
inequalities
will be difficult after the murder of
george floyd
reforming the police will also be a
priority
we've all seen the name of injustice on
the neck of black americans
now is our opportunity to make some real
progress
to rebuild trust between law enforcement
and the people they serve
to root out systemic racism in our
criminal justice system
and to enact police reform in george
floyd's name
how to lay the foundations for an
american century will not come
easily resistance from the republicans
will make some of his agenda impossible
but for now at least it's clear that
this president
who's waited a long time for this moment
is dreaming big
[Applause]
well alex is live in washington for us
this morning
how has this gone down i mean both in
congress alex but also i've been
crucially especially at the moment
amongst the american public
well it's very difficult to ascertain at
the moment certainly this speech was
joe biden setting out his stall not just
of course to the the people here
in the beltway in washington dc but he's
speaking directly stephen to the
american people
as well you heard about the amount of
money that he wants to spend nearly four
trillion dollars trying to revamp the
american economy with
infrastructure jobs money for families
uh dealing with the coronavirus pandemic
i mean it's the kind of largesse
federal largesse this country really
hasn't seen
in modern times you probably need to
reach back till
i don't know the second world war really
to get that kind of spending power
and he wants to sell that uh to the
american people now certainly
amongst those americans who are
receiving paychecks
already in their bank accounts to help
out in the covert crisis
there is some support bipartisan support
but amongst republicans now to them this
smells like
a big government this smells like
interference and they don't want
anything to do with it he's obviously
calling for unity
but he's unlikely to unite uh the united
states
on this particular issue but joe biden
was also trying to do something else he
was
setting himself up as a transitional
president there were two things in this
speech one was mentioned
over and over again that was coronavirus
there was another thing that was very
present there that wasn't mentioned at
all
and that was donald trump but trump was
present
all the time in this speech joe biden is
setting himself
up as the man who can move the country
uh beyond the years
of his predecessor okay alex thank you
now there's lots to talk about in terms
of britain's response to the pandemic
this morning so
delighted to say we're joined by the
vaccines minister nadim zahawi really
good to see you
in the flesh finally it makes a lovely
change
um look it's the government still being
driven by data and not dates in our
response
very much so and if you recall when the
prime minister set out the
road map to reopening the economy he
talked about the four tests one
is vaccines need to continue to be
deployed at scale
vaccine efficacy we're seeing some
really good data in terms of vaccine
protection
and now from public health england the
vax is working against household
transmission cutting it by 50
3 obviously infection rates because the
virus will attempt
to infect more people to mutate and then
the fourth is the mutations
so the four weeks plus one the five week
period is really important because
there's four weeks of data gathering
as we open up we had a big opening uh
this month on 12th
april of the economy um the data's
looking good
and positive but nevertheless we really
have to be careful
because what we don't want is mutations
for example
to blindside us and then have another
spike and yet jonathan van tam said
didn't it you know if if
people were fully vaccinated it would be
incredibly safe in his word for them to
meet up and have some physical contact
all that sort of thing
with that in mind can't we use things a
little bit more for those people who are
fully vaccinated so this is why we have
to be careful i think
the the full quote was um yes of course
uh they are incredibly safe if they are
fully vaccinated so two doses
at the moment only one in four
adults have actually had the two doses
now
we're accelerating second doses april
has been second dose
month but let me give it to you let me
sort of give you the flip side why we
have to be careful on this
if the vaccines have 85 percent efficacy
and we vaccinate fully 85
of the na of the adult population that
still is only 72
percent protection so there's still
quite a sizable
um percentage for the virus to go after
and infect
which is why we've got to be careful
hence why the four weeks of data
collection
and then one week of analysis and then
moving to the next step now the good
news is
we're not seeing any evidence that would
lead us to believe that we can't meet
the next step in may the really
important step 17th of may and then
ultimately
obviously the 21st of june but it's much
better to be careful
and follow the data collect the data
properly analyze it and then
make a decision then to we all want to
obviously get our
freedoms back as quickly as possible um
but
let's do this properties do it safely
well in terms of that
there's obviously now the talk about a a
booster and a 60 million
fisa vaccines have been bought or
being bought where does that leave us in
terms of
of sort of cross-vaccination is that
going to be
fisa vaccines given to to people as a
booster whatever else they've taken in
the past
so for this current deployment so phase
one we've just completed the over 50s
everybody's been offered a first dose
of course we're now second dosings i
explained
that deployment continues so if you've
had pfizer you'll get a five second dose
you've had astrozenica you've got any
secondary
moderna moderna we have two clinical
trials that are
important one uh is the mix and match
trial which we've put
seven million pounds to fund that will
report at the
end of the summer that will help us for
future proofing
and planning of vaccination campaigns
the second one which jonathan van tan
referred to last night
which is the cove boost trial
which looks at which booster vaccine
single shot would be the best
now what we want to do and my focus at
the moment is to give the scientists
as many options as possible for that
future proofing whether it's pfizer
astrazeneca astrozenica variant val neva
the scottish
manufactured vaccine and of course
novovax which works extremely well
against both the current dominant
virus which is the kent virus and the
south african virus i mean i spoke to
sir john bell
who's on the vaccine task force a couple
of weeks ago and
he was very much of the opinion looking
at the data he'd seen that actually
mixing the vaccines
would give a much stronger immune
response
which is why we've got the mix and match
uh clinical trials
they'll report at the end of the summer
the booster
uh trials as well the kov boost trials
will also be able to tell us
which booster shot would be the most
suitable and of course
the scientists will then have to decide
whether you
boost obviously the most if you recall
the most vulnerable
to covert we began vaccinating on the
8th of december
with pfizer and then 4th of january with
astrazeneca
so i want to give the scientists as many
choices of
vaccines to be able to use as a booster
they will decide whether
we go september or later in this year or
early next year depending on the
durability
of the current vaccination program
but we need to give them that ability to
have as many
different vaccines in their armory to be
able to continue
to manage the virus and i think we will
begin by next year
to hopefully move from pandemic to
endemic and treat it like we would do
with a flu vaccination program and the
other bit obviously that the nhs
is planning at the moment is how do you
dovetail a covert boost
campaign with the flu vaccination
program
in the autumn look i can appreciate
you're in a very difficult position
because i mean
your priority your focus is is
vaccinating
the united kingdom but when you're
looking at buying all these extra
vaccines so this is the 60
million doses of of pfizer when we don't
quite know if that's going to be the
right approach for everybody and you
said getting lots of these different
vaccines on board
well we know there is still this huge
global problem
at what point do we start to look at
this from westminster
as a global issue that we need to start
dealing with
really important questions so literally
from the inception
of the vaccines task force when the
prime minister set up the vaccine stasis
he gave us two priorities one find the
vaccines
that will work against this virus so go
out and look
and find them manufacture them in the uk
if you can
contract early if they're not
manufacturing the uk and get them here
but the second priority from back in
march of 2020
is how do you help the rest of the world
he said to have a plan of how we have
so we're the first country to put 548
billion pounds to the kovacs which is
the infrastructure that's now delivering
40 million vaccines of landed for over
100 countries so
the philippines and ghana and ivory
coast
have all been receiving kovacs the bulk
of it by the way is the oxford
astrozenica vaccine
the oxford team and astrazeneca are not
making any profit on that it's being
done at
cost whilst we're in pandemic around the
world
so we are doing a hell of a lot to make
sure we help the rest of
india has historically been there for
our
nhs many many colleagues who work in the
nhs are of
indian heritage it's really important
we're one of the first countries to help
in the
hundreds of pieces of
health machinery that was needed by them
including oxygen concentrators
went out to india but we're also through
oxford and astrazeneca
giving the serum institute the ability
to manufacture 70 million
doses a month for india and other
low-income countries
okay look you mentioned the prime
minister can we talk about his current
predicament um
sakia stammer said on television last
night
with these investigations inquiries that
are underway this could all be over in
five minutes he said if the prime
minister just tells us what went on
with the refurb of his flat why doesn't
he do that
well first of all the prime minister has
answered
umpteen questions on this including as
your viewers would say
would want to know did the taxpayer pay
for the refurbishment
or not he paid for the refurbishment
unlike previous prime ministers tony
blair i think spent
some like 300 000 pounds on refurbishing
uh the flat in
number turnover time but here's the the
problem for kirsten i listened very
carefully to him last night
because he did a big sit-down interview
with robert peston 10 minutes
of that and pt barnum would have been
proud of him
he was the ultimate bandwagoner not a
single policy idea for an election
important elections coming up in seven
days time
all he could talk about yeah but come on
people was this question but people
could say the same about you saying well
you're trying to dodge you're trying to
dodge the issue by by talking about
their lack of policy suggestions
well we do have we have elections we
have elections in seven days time but
people want to know what you're going to
do are you going to be delivering a
vaccine program are you going to
deliver a leveling up agenda where we're
investing
640 billion in infrastructure but the
prime minister has said as you said he
said repeatedly
i paid for this refurbishment well he
might have done in the end what we want
to know is
where was the money coming from
originally the talk of 58 000 coming
from one donor loans from cchq did any
of that actually happen
well first of all the uh prime minister
has appointed lord guy who was the
majesty the queen's um private secretary
across venture
in the house was really important the
reforms we've made
to the way uh lord
can effectively do his job is to allow
him to be proactive
in his investigation uh the prime
minister will
absolutely make sure that he
delivers everything that lord guide asks
for to be able to conduct that
investigation the premise has been very
clear that he paid for this that he
also followed all the ministerial codes
took advice and if lord guide in his
investigation
requires the prime minister to make any
other declarations then he will also
so that's a commitment is it because
ultimately as it stands the prime
minister
is the ultimate arbiter of this own
investigation he would know he could he
could dismiss it he could just dismiss
the recommendations you saying that
that whatever lord comes up with
independently
will be acted upon so this is a really
important question
part of our reforms now allow
lord guy to be able to be proactive
rather than reactive
all ministers serve with the confidence
of the prime minister
he's appointed lord guy to look at
ministers
and ministerial conduct it's only right
i serve because i have the confidence of
the prime minister if i don't have that
confidence
i will clearly lose my job so
ultimately the prime minister has done
everything in his power to answer these
questions
we've got elections in seven days time
labor at the moment
are a policy-free zone uh i worry
because
the voters will look at kirsten i think
they'll probably
be thinking well you know where where
are the ideas
where are you what are you going to do
to better my life how are you going to
give me a job at the end of this
pandemic are you going to back
this country being able to do the
vaccinations that it needs which you
know
is important to make sure we come out of
this pandemic okay
as possible we will find out what the
voters think in a week or so
we're really good to see you this
morning thank you very much indeed
just to remind you that you want to
catch up on any of that interview or
watch the program when you're out and
about this morning then you can do so
on the sky news website or our mobile
app you can
go to our live blog to watch the program
and catch up on the interviews on my
twitter
which is at sky steven
talk to our political correspondent kate
mccann what do you think kate i think on
the
coveted stuff there's clearly some
really positive news on vaccinations but
there are some questions given what
jonathan vantam said about people who
are vaccinated being able to meet
clearly the government is sticking to
its data collection and then the dates
it set for itself but of course
in the beginning there were lots of
people who wanted them to
who wanted to see you know it be led by
the data rather than the dates
slightly confusing but when things are
getting better they're still being very
cautious about it so i think there will
be some questions on that but
warner jeans are highly said to you at
the end there about the prime minister
and about this investigation is really
interesting because lord guy at the
moment doesn't have the power to trigger
investigations on his own
we know that labour party have asked the
government to make that
happen but as things stand he
can't trigger an investigation himself
the prime minister is the only person
who can do that
but nadeem sahar we just said to you
he's proactive now rather than reactive
so i would love to know what that
actually means because while he can
investigate things and while he's been
given more power to make sure that these
reports are published in a timely
fashion he still couldn't for example
trigger his own investigation into boris
johnson's conduct without the prime
minister
signing off on it and as labour have
said at the moment that is a real
problem
okay okay thank you
now more than 18 million people in india
now
have coronavirus with nearly 205 000
having lost their lives sawing another
record rise in cases
and deaths the united states says it
will give india more than a hundred
million dollars in drugs and medical
supplies
the crisis has crippled the country's
health care system and created a
desperate rush for oxygen supplies
our special correspondent alex crawford
sent this report
from delhi this is a cue for
air in the world's biggest democracy the
hunt for oxygen is getting more
urgent
the man on the right says they're not
filling up the cylinders completely
lives are at stake and every extra
breath of oxygen
counts right now a young man is pleading
brother my grandmother is on her
deathbed and the hospital sent me
please fill mine he's lucky he's pushed
his way to the top of a very long
queue and got away with it all
businesses with oxygen supplies have
been told to give them over for medical
use now
my grandmother how badly ill is she if
we don't give oxygen she will die in
hospital
hospital say no oxygen so you're taking
this to the hospital yes
these cylinders have become the lifeline
for many indians
but harshit's grandmother needs them
filled every two hours to keep her alive
and the hospital is in another state it
is very far
and no one is allowed to go inside my
grandma inside and my younger brother
surrender no one else how long will it
take you to get to the hospital
one hour
[Music]
across the city there's another line but
the shop hasn't yet got its oxygen
delivery
and some of these people have been
waiting since three in the morning
they're still here eight hours later
should have some plans to do this thing
but they didn't do anything the
government of delhi
didn't do anything and that's why people
are suffering in every shop there is no
oxygen
there is no oxygen black market is on
high
black market is on high when you go to
hospital there is no
oxygen delhi is under
lockdown now but part of the criticism
is that they lifted it far too early and
there were crowds of people
all gathering at political rallies
indians are now dependent
on cylinders partly because several
governments have restricted
oxygen manufacturing here in the capital
to just small-scale industries
they've spent only around two percent of
the country's gdp or income
on the health industry it's meant
charities have had to step
in to provide oxygen for very sick
people who can't get it
elsewhere it's all on a very small scale
but for some it's vital
she's been under this tree for two days
cared for by her son obviously
struggling
the family wanted us to show this they
want their own government
and others to see what's happening here
and everywhere now top 10 oxygen
available in all hospitals
others are running dangerously low
harpreet has probably only about half an
hour of oxygen left
yeah it's almost exhausted you can see
over here
their load arrives in the nick of time
this hand to mouth surviving because
many believe the government declared
covert victory far too early and didn't
plan ahead
the lack of oxygen generating units
means hospitals and their patients
are reliant on supplies coming in from
far too few plants
around the country in this hospital they
have less than a handful of tanks
and their storage is being used up every
few hours
so the head of the hospitals decided to
buy his own oxygen manufacturing unit
so we can order five plants so that can
just have a capacity of almost like
5000 cylinders a day he sourced one from
turkey
and is hoping it will be here within
seven to ten days
now since we have experienced this that
in times of crisis
we can land up in such a situation where
the life of the patient is put to risk
i think we need to take some steps so
that we become more independent
and not depend on the weak supply chain
mechanism which is there
existing currently but india is still in
the grip of a coronavirus nightmare
and tens of thousands of its citizens
can't think days ahead
whilst they're struggling to breathe
hour to hour
alex crawford sky news delhi
the fbi has carried out searches at the
manhattan apartment and office of rudy
giuliani who was previously donald
trump's personal lawyer
the rage is part of an investigation
into the form of new york city's mayor's
business dealings in ukraine
mr giuliani's lawyer denies he's broken
the law and has called the searches
legal thuggery a woman has been arrested
after four people were found dead inside
a hospital in germany
the fifth person was left seriously
injured inside the clinic in potsdam
german media is reporting all of the
victims of patients
and the woman arrested is an employee at
the clinic
the russian opposition leader alexia
navalny is due in court this morning it
could be the first time he's been seen
since starting a hunger strike in prison
he's appealing against his conviction
for
defaming a world war ii veteran
scientists say one of the largest ice
shelves in antarctica
is at risk of collapsing because of warm
mountain winds
they say the shelf is being hit by gusts
warmed by
increasing levels of greenhouse gases
and just to remind you you can see the
daily climate show later at half past
six
and half past nine here on sky news
now the united nations says cuts in
british aid will have a devastating
effect on its work to reduce maternal
and child
deaths around the world let's get more
from our foreign affairs editor debra
haynes just
what are we paying for at the moment
deborah
well the uk back in 2019 committed to
spend
425 million pounds
on a program that's run by this un
agency
which is all about family planning as
you say and it was at the time
billed as the biggest financial
partnership
that the agency had ever experienced in
its history
a hugely significant moment and a big
pat on the back
for the uk and this year alone the uk
had committed for that programme which
like you said
it provides life-saving family planning
support to women and girls
in the poorest parts of the world
including advice about well including
condoms
other forms of contraceptives and then
maternal medicines which
really does help to stop unintended
pregnancies
prevent dangerous abortions and also
give life-saving help to women and girls
and
and enable them empower them to be able
to go on and and
go to education rather than become
mothers at an early age
um but the the agency now says this 150
million pounds that the uk
had committed to spend has been slashed
to just over
20 million pounds and has warned that
that funding that's gone
could have gone to help um about a
quarter of a million
uh men and girls and children that might
now
die okay deborah thank you
this is sky news breakfast let's get a
check on the weather for you today
with isabelle are we still going to see
a bit of rain and drizzle today as well
uh well there'll be more typical sort of
april showers that type of thing stephen
but one thing's for sure it's feeling
cold
really disappointing temperatures this
month i talked yesterday about it being
the frostiest
april and it looks as though it'll be
probably the third maybe second sunniest
on record
and obviously that's led to clear skies
overnight and frost but let's take a
look at what we've got out and about
today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
so a little bit different to yesterday
yesterday we did have some heavy rain
across the south some parts of south
wales and dorset collected around an
inch of rain 25 millimeters
today it's a different flavor to things
it starts off mostly bright with some
sunshine
the clouds bubble up and then we'll see
some showers developing probably few if
any showers across the south
most of them across the north where they
could be heavy potentially
some hail mixed in and it's cold 8 to 12
degrees with that northerly breeze
through this evening and tonight the
winds ease a touch and inland we could
see a little bit of frost in the
countryside
and again tomorrow the month closes on a
chilly note a little bit of frost in the
countryside first thing
showers become more widespread through
the day with a few heavy ones
in the southwest as you can see stays
chilly
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you still to come on sky
news breakfast
turning crisis into opportunity
president biden talks about life
after the pandemic
pony about half a mile from the turkish
coast and
it's evident that there's a boat
seriously overcrowded
this is one of the most severe viruses
in the world
i'm alex crawford and i'm sky's special
correspondent based in istanbul
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in the news
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin
and very frail her arms look at her arms
i can
put my entire hand round
[Music]
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
once it takes hold it's very very
difficult for these firefighters to
get a grip of it and get on top of it
and put it out
the world's largest folds now down to a
charcoal in places
i can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge lake
getting up close and personal with a
rhino
this is what makes the job so
[Music]
fantastic
[Music]
[Music]
now the government says it doesn't want
people who've had two vaccine doses to
meet up
before lockdown rules are eased it comes
as the uk deputy chief medical officer
jonathan van tam said he believed it was
incredibly safe for
fully vaccinated people to meet but the
vaccines minister nadim zahari told me
restrictions would not be relaxed early
the good news is we're not seeing any
evidence
that would lead us to believe that we
can't meet the next step in may
the really important step 17th of may
and then ultimately obviously the 21st
of june
but it's much better to be careful and
follow the data
collect the data properly analyze it and
then make a decision
then to we all want to obviously get our
freedoms back as quickly as possible
but let's do this properties do it
safely
now president biden promised a huge wave
of public spending last night as he
outlined plans for life
after the pandemic in a speech to
congress marking his first hundred days
in office
president biden said america was on the
move again
well let's talk to caeprie cafaro who's
in ohio a democrat who was former leader
of the ohio senate
and the former republican congressional
candidate joe collins
who's in los angeles good to see you
both this morning and joe can i get your
reaction first and foremost to what
president biden said last night
well i think it was probably one of his
better speeches i was
really looking for some outline on how
he plans to move
his agenda forward but with the amount
of spending that he's been doing you
know when i was younger we used to trash
politicians who increased the national
debt
but at this point it's being praised for
some reason i think the long-term
effects of
this much spending is something that
people are not calculating now his plan
is the tax people who make over 400 000
uh dollars a year in taxi major
corporations but
i don't think he takes into effect the
amount of money that you could attack
these companies
does not even equate to the amount of
spending that he's doing so when it
comes to that type of budget i'm really
not a fan i think that they should go
back to the drawing board and create a
new plan
okay capri i mean certainly he was
claiming that he's achieved an awful lot
in his first hundred days and is that a
justifiable claim
well it depends on the aspect of policy
that you're looking at so for example
when it comes to the vaccine rollout
dealing with the covet
pandemic certainly has a lot to
um you know be proud of no question
about that
now in the united states anyone over the
uh
age of 16 has the opportunity to get a
vaccine
now he has a lot of other challenges for
example when it comes to things like
immigration um so and he also
passed the american recovery act which
i agree with my colleague spends a lot
of money but it also puts a lot of money
back into the pockets of the american
people
fourteen hundred dollars for anybody
that is earning
uh less than i believe it's seventy two
thousand dollars a year
so there's a lot of good um that joe
biden has achieved in the first hundred
days
in terms of of the the pandemic response
and the vaccination response we know
he's way ahead of target
on this uh joe do you do you think he's
doing better than his predecessor would
have done if the election had gone the
other way
well i think that you know judging from
the situation president trump being in
office whenever
the pandemic had first started and joe
biden right now
being the person who is in office i
think that the the push to get people
vaccinated with this vaccine has been
extraordinary and i think
both uh presidents did a really great
job of getting the vaccination out and
uh doing what they can to ensure the
american people and even across the
entire world
that this vaccination was shaped and it
was going to help uh
you know solve the problem with the with
the covert 19 so
i would have to agree when it comes to
the vaccination process i mean
you know bar none he did a really great
job his predecessor
did a really great job but joe biden is
the president right now and i look
forward to
seeing how this whole vaccination
process is going to work out here in
america
what do you think joe though about i
mean obviously in terms of moving
forward
one of the big issues is how divided the
country
has been after the last administration
and particularly
on the the racial issue and with the
verdict on george floyd on that killing
i mean that there are whole issues which
are being opened up here
that there's an awful lot to unite isn't
it so that is a very difficult task
yeah it is a lot to unite and i think
what people have to do when they stop
saying that every single thing that's
happened to people of color
uh is racist and we have to stop the
white guild as well
um i think we need to move forward with
a plan where our politicians are
creating legislation that's going to be
positive
and it's going to benefit all americans
not just one group of americans because
you think that certain things are
disparities i like the way joe biden
signs
um his bills and a lot of his executive
orders and so i think that we need to
start removing policies that has been
ineffective
over the years and started replacing it
with new policies that could potentially
increase the
quality of life for the american people
yeah i mean this this is the issue
though
capri isn't it the fact that that
america has become
for whatever reason who you want to
blame for is up to you of course but
it's become so polarized over the last
few years
it really is incredibly tragic and and
as a former
lawmaker you know i've seen this play
out at the state level and at the
federal level
and it really is unfortunate and you're
right there are a
lot of parties to blame and as a result
joe biden has a very heavy lift to try
to unite this nation
and i would say that the first half of
the speech this evening
was trying to reach out build bridges
for example to the people i used to
represent
blue-collar americans that were
attracted to
donald trump because of his stance on
trade for example
and so uh joe biden this evening was
very focused in the first half of the
speech
trying to reach out to those those
moderates talking about the economy
talking about how he was going to create
jobs how he was going to organize labor
how he was going to increase wages
and then on the flip side in the second
half he was trying to appeal
to the progressive base of the
democratic party talking about racial
justice issues
um talking about gun violence and a
number of other things
um and it i think it's very reflective
of the of the challenges that joe biden
has
trying to unite this nation and
try to appeal to the republicans while
at the same time
trying to assuage uh the progressive uh
wing of the democratic party do you
think he is being
successful joe in that i mean i've been
struck by the fact that you have been
anything
but dismissive of president biden i mean
you you may not have voted for him but
you're not dismissing what he's doing
no he's the president of the united
states and i have to respect that i am a
guy who served 13 and a half
years in the united states navy under
democrats and republicans
you know and i i think he's doing a good
job for the position that he was put in
one thing i would like to see looking
back from the clintons to the bushes to
the obamas to the trumps the bidens
is an administration that will build off
the suspects of
the previous administration i think that
will bring the entire country together i
mean like you know it's okay to
criticize policy
but let's build up the success of the
policies and let's remove what didn't
work replace it with something
that did work i think that's something
that all of america can appreciate
would you agree with that capri
absolutely and i feel as if
my colleague in los angeles and i uh
should work together as democrats and
republicans and find a way
to build consensus because that is the
only way forward in this nation
and it is a real tragedy uh for a leader
in democracy to be facing what we've
been facing in the last
five six and even even further back
um so i totally agree and i'm so glad to
hear a republican
across the aisle um being committed to
bipartisanship
could they just ask about the uh the the
the jobs for american people you're
gonna we're gonna make america and we're
gonna buy american
uh we're gonna keep the money sort of
within america
if you like i mean that was i was a
little bit surprised that he came out
with that
in some respects but but do you think
that is going to appeal
certainly to to republican voters joe
i think so one of the biggest issues
that we have here in america is that
you know because of the huge amount of
taxes that companies face
they are taking their manufacturing
overseas
and so if we can incentivize companies
to come back to america will build
america
sell america i think a lot of people
will get on board with that message
republican democrat alike especially
with the younger generation because one
thing that we have to understand is that
the young republicans the young
democrats the young independents are
going to have to bear the load
of the responsibilities that the older
generation have left to us so yes build
america sell america in america
is absolutely an agenda that i can get
on board with i mean
i guess capri i mean it's classic
working towards the center ground isn't
it
well here's what i would say uh donald
trump was successful
in communities like mine traditionally
democrat working class
because of his stance on labor unions
and trade for example and so
the fact that joe biden is talking about
these issues
is incredibly appealing i think to
uh really important parts of the
american electorate
well look really good to talk to you
both this morning and nice to have a bit
of consensus
across the aisle as you say good to see
you thank you
thank thank you now still to come on sky
news breakfast
doctors tell us they think that not
enough of us are going for
proper laboratory cobia tests more
details in a moment
what do you do what do we say
it's smoking mirrors
there was a there was a sense of
frustration with all the lights in the
bond that that
that uh what we were seeing unfold
across the
and particularly across the pandemic but
prior to that as well was
was people just not being able to afford
the the basics of life and also
that the the they're just and
it and it just started to increase an
increase in increasing we just thought
well look we've got to do something
about this and you know
and on the back of the fantastic um
fantastic work
that that you know that was happening
around
around food banks but we were just
frustrated about that in the uk
in 2021 there was a necessity for them
which was
which was shocking to us um
and you know people use food banks for
various reasons it's not just one
it's just not not just one reason it's
in a it's a it's an accumulative effect
of maybe losing a job or
carers or you know
and it was just shopping for us so we
wanted to do we wanted to do something
to raise awareness of the issue but also
to to just bring a little bit of light
and air into the
into that what is quite a heavy subject
and nobody wants to be in a position
where
by the they that they can't that they
can't um
supply food and the absolute basic
necessities for the families
and um and and that's awful that's
that's an awful position to be in
and it's an awful and and it was just
and it's just kind of this reaction
to it's for them the track is for them
it's just you know we're waiting for the
summer waiting for a few better days
the pandemics not been great in fact
it's been a disaster for many many
people
and as always when things like this hits
societies
it's always it's always the people that
are less fortunate the poor the working
class that actually
take it on the nose and we we we just we
just couldn't sit back and watch it
really
and um and you know and all the great
work that marcus did march rashford and
all of all all of
all of that movement towards actually
look
this is what's happening in our country
and it's not acceptable to us so we need
to make
choices and changes that we need to make
to
to stop this because 25 years ago we
didn't need to advance
why do we need them now
[Music]
for the early
the knowledge risers welcome to divided
states
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
for wherever you are welcome to the
safety ridge what's happening
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that if we make
small changes to our lives we can reduce
air pollution by
loads but how much exactly
loads well the weather is chilly but
quite typical for april in that
the day will start off fine for many
inland areas and then the clouds will
bubble up and we'll see showers
developing
showers mainly across central and
northern areas many southern parts
probably escaping with largely dry
weather
quite chilly though particularly on the
north sea coast eight or nine celsius
there and even in the south only 11 or
12 so
well below average for the time of year
with the cloud breaking to give a frost
tonight and air quality well as you can
imagine it is good in this air mass so
low levels of air pollution for most
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now some doctors say they're worried
that not enough of us are going for
what would they call a proper
coronavirus test and instead of relying
on the kits
that can be used at home they say more
of us
need to have the pcr test rather than
the lateral flow test they're the ones
that give you a very quick result well
let's talk to dr angela raffel public
health consultants with experience
in communicable disease control and
screening programs good to see you this
morning
why are you not happy about the the
number of lateral flow tests being taken
so the british medical journal asked me
to write
an editorial this week and it isn't as
simple as
lateral flow tests bad pcr tests could
it's all about how we run our testing
system
so test and trace needs to focus on
those
who are most at risk people who've got
symptoms no matter how mild
and anybody and everybody they've been
in contact with and then there needs to
be support to isolate
that has to be the backbone of pandemic
control
and what we're saying is that needs to
go on getting better it has been getting
better
but it needs to get way better still and
we're going to need that in the long
term
and the new approach of home tests for
everybody
what we're saying is that hasn't been
evaluated it could be
a complete waste of time and effort and
we need better studies
there's really no basis for that policy
why a complete waste of time and effort
because we know that
we know the tests aren't as accurate but
they they've got to be picking up
some positive results haven't they
there isn't a there's not an expert body
in the world that recommends
focusing on people at the lowest risk so
the cdc in america the who
they don't say test test test
lots of people at home who haven't been
in contact
what they say is test the people who've
been in contact with cases
test when there's an outbreak test when
you've got very high risk
areas so it's more about who we're
targeting the test to
and then the other aspect is the natural
flow tests potentially are really really
useful
but we have no evidence at all about how
well they work
when they're done by untrained people on
themselves
and we need some studies on that so
we've got
two important pieces of evidence one was
the really hard work they did in
liverpool where they tested a quarter of
the city
it didn't make any impact on the surge
of infections over christmas
it didn't make any impact on
hospitalizations and deaths
and another is a study recently
published comparing
care homes that were doing actual flow
testing with care homes that weren't
didn't make a difference to outbreaks
and the staff said it was very hard to
stick to the protocol
what they really need is more more
staffing so they can follow infection
control procedures
yeah but when you talk about you know
there's there's no point in mass testing
where there's no evidence that anyone's
been in
in contact with a positive case i mean
it isn't part of the problem here that
what is it 33 or so of all cases are
asymptomatic
so how would anybody know if they've
been in contact
there's a difference between how many
people who contract the virus
show symptoms versus where does most of
the transmission comes from
so the overwhelming evidence at the
moment is that the vast majority of
transmission
comes from people with symptoms that may
be related to the fact that they're
coughing more
it may be that they have higher viral
loads i think
there is a real wish that we could
catch people in that time between when
they've got infected and when they start
showing symptoms
but the best way to try and do that is
by
contact tracing so everybody who's been
in contact with someone
who's got a case either in the two days
before they got it you know
are they the place they got it from or
who's been in contact with them since
they've had symptoms
but testing ordinary healthy people at
home who haven't had much contact
is i mean it's very hard to see where
the government got the idea for that
policy they dumped it up last summer
and i don't expect they'll change their
minds they've spent three billion
pounds on lateral flow tests and now
they've got to use them up
look in terms then of what you would
ideally like to see
would that include more pcr tests being
you know done at the driving centers or
whatever because
i mean clearly with that there's i mean
that could be a logistical nightmare
couldn't it
we have i mean the government has built
an amazing capacity for testing in the
uk we do
more tests per case detected
than anywhere else in the world at the
moment
so we're just not using those tests to
best effect
we have underused capacity for doing pcr
tests
there are many other promising rapid
tests in the pipeline
that can give a very quick turnaround we
could for example use these
laptop load tests at the test and trace
centers to give people a very quick
result
and then send some of the sample for pcr
we should be able to do pcr
with a 24-hour turnaround and that is
getting better and better
so what i'd like to see is more studies
of whether symptomless
testing of low-risk people is worthwhile
more studies of how well these tests
perform
when done by people who aren't trained
but primarily
test trace and support to isolate
getting better and better
and better dr raffle good to talk to you
thank you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
it's right up there being one of the top
three sunniest april's but my word it's
a chilly one and it ends on a chilly
note as well
we've got a frost this morning and we've
got a north or north easterly wind
over us as well not particularly
pleasant out there uh temperatures
struggling to about 8 to 12 degrees
today really disappointing for the time
of year
at least there is some sunshine for many
this morning but it's one of those days
where the shower clouds will develop and
there will be
quite a scattering of april showers
through the day some hail
across the northeast maybe some snow for
northern peaks as well but i think
southern air is probably missing the
showers
and staying dry for most of the time and
then as we head through the evening the
showers fade
long clear spells develop and again
we're expecting a touch of frost tonight
not
particularly harsh frost but there will
be a little bit of frost to wake up to
as we head our way into
friday morning and then again after that
nice start the shower clouds will
develop and we end the month with
some hefty showers maybe more than today
across the south west of the country as
well with temperatures around 8 in the
northeast
11 or 12 in the south